فقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد رئيسه
الحكومه نجلاء بودن وعين احمد الحشاني
خلفا لها في اول خطوه من نوعها بعد اعتماد
النظام الرئاسي في تونس وادى الحشال وهو
قانوني متقاعد عمل بالبنك المركزي اليمين
الدستوريه مساء الثلاثاء امام الرئيس قيس
سعيد وتاتي هذه الخطوه في ظل ازمه
اقتصاديه ومعيشيه خانقه وانسداد في الافق
السياسي بالبلاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات بل اليات التي اتخذها
سعيد للتوصل الى قرار اقاله رئيسه الحكومه
وما مدى ارتباط هذا القرار بالتطورات
السياسيه والصعوبه الاقتصاديه التي تمر
بها تونس ثم ما المعايير التي اختار سعيد
على اساسها رئيس الحكومه الجديد وما فرص
نجاحه في حل الازمات التي تواجهها تونس
على ضوء الصلاحيه الرهينه للرئيس ثم نبحث
فيما يقوله هذا القرار عن مستقبل السياسه
والديمقراطيه في تونس وكيف يمكن مقارنه
اداء واليات تعيين حكومات حقبه سعيد
بسابقاتها من حكومات ما بعد الثوره
[موسيقى]
قوبي الى منتصفي ليل الثلاثاء الاربعاء
وبدون تقديم مبررات للقرار او تقرير عن
ادائها اقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
رئيسه الحكومه نجلاء مدن وعين احمد
الحشاني خلفا لها الحشان الذي ادى اليمين
الدستوريه امام الرئيس سعيد قانوني متقاعد
كان يعمل في البنك المركزي ولم يعرف عنه
اي انتماء سياسي او تجربه سابقه في العمل
العام امر امر اعتبره معارضون غير مبشر
لجهه قدرته على مواجهه الازمات الاقتصاديه
الخانقه والانسداد السياسي الذي تعيشه
البلاد حاليا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من سوسه شرق
تونس قيصر الصياح المحامي والباحث في
القانون ومن مدينه رفراف شمال تونس سمير
ديلو المحامي وعضو اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه
الخلاص الوطني المعارضه اهلا بكما ابدى
بضيف من
سوسه السيد قيصر الصياح لمحاوله فهم
الاساس الذي على اساسه اولا اتخاذ الرئيس
سعيد لقرار اقاله بودن اكثر سؤال مطروح في
تونس عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اسباب اقاله بودن
شكرا مساء الخير اولا لك ولضيفك ولا اخ
سمير ولا الاستاذ سمير
المتطلبات المرحله الجديده وصعوبه المرحله
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه التي تمر بها
الدوله منظرها
منذ سنه 2018 تقريبا عقب تحصلنا على عدد
قروض بالاف المليارات
ذهبت هباء المنثوره ولم تحصل منها الدوله
على شيء وبقيت خزائن دوله فارغه تقريبا
التمام والكمال الى ان بلغنا 110 الف
مليار ديون ثم عجز ميزان تجاري 42 الف
مليار وهذه ارقام مفزعه ومرعبه حتى في
وكالات التصنيف العالميه والدول الشقيقه
والصديقه ثم اصبحنا غير قادرين حتى على
السداد نتيجه تراكم تلك الديون القديمه
التي كنا نتحصل عليها بدون ضمانات وتبذر
في التعيينات وتبذر في الانتدابات
العشوائيه التي بلغت 120 الف تقريبا
بشهاده مزوره لحد الان تكلف تونس 4000
مليار سنويا من الخسائر ثم ان المرحله
الجديده
يتطلبها التدخل العاجل اثره اجراء مذكره
التفاهم مع الاتحاد الاوروبي والرغبه في
ادماج الفضاء الاقتصادي التونسي بالفضاء
الاقتصاديه الاوروبي رغم ان البعض يقول ان
هذا نوع من الاستعمار الجديد التي تفرض
على تونس هذه المذكره التي دخلنا فيها
والتي تؤكد وتجسد وتعمق اتفاق سابق واتفاق
سراق المعمق المسمى بالاليكا والذي تجبر
في تونس على 12 لتنفيذ الجبري والقصر
الفوري فهنا وجد نفسه الرئيس امام مرحله
جديده يعرفه هو فقط وهو الذي اختار بنفسه
تعقيبا على التساؤل الذي بدانا به الحوار
كيف اختار وما هي الاليات انا اؤكد لك مئه
بالمئه ان الرئيس اختار من قرارات نفسه
باعتبار
انهكرات وهذا الرجل هو مدير عام سابق
للشؤون القانونيه وتسريعه بالبنك المركزي
ويعرف خفايا الفساد وخفايا صفقات والاموال
المبذره على ذلك
قيصر لماذا يصبح هذا السؤال
طبعا في ظل نظام رئاسي الرئيس هو في من
يحدد فيه كل شيء قلت بان القادم لقصر
الحكومه تقني وبالتالي ايضا ماذا كانت
السيده بودن تكلمت عن صعوبات وبالتالي
مسؤوليه من اذا كانت حكومه السيده بوتين
قد فشلت مسؤوليه من في ظل النظام الحالي
نظام الراغن وهو النظام الرئاسي الذي يقرر
فيه الرئيس كل شيء
الرئيس قال تقريبا في خطابه الذي سمعه كل
الناس اليوم تقريبا من يتعمق في قراءه
فواصل ذلك الخطاب بتحليل السياسي معمق
وفكر عميق يجد مصطلحين اثنين واضحين الى
الرئيس الرئيس فكر هو تكنوكرات حتى عندما
عين هشام المشيشي وبودنه في المرحله
الفارطه اختار التكنوكراد الرئيس اختار
بودن كطواف للمرور الى مرحله ثانيه يعرفها
هو فقط يعرفها البعض من المحللين
السياسيين لانه يريد ان ينتقل بتونس من
تلك المرحله الاولى التي هي في عمق زجاجه
والتي يصطدم فيها باحزاب معارضه وضعيات
سياسيه حرجه جدا الى مرحله ثانيه ونراها
في خطاب اليوم عندما قال ليس النظام الذي
احكمه الان هو الفاسد الفاسده هي المظلوم
ويجب اصلاحه وبالتالي الرئيس يعتبر ان
العشر سنوات وذكر اليوم كلمه عشر سنوات
سوداء وذكر من يرقصون من المسرح واعتبر
عبارات وسنه العبارات باعتبار انه يرى ان
المنظومه القديمه هي سبب الخطاب وانه يجب
ان ينتقل بتونس برجل تكنوكرات جديد قادر
على الاقل على معرفه الخفايا
ايضا السيده سمير فيما يتعلق بما اننا
امام تجربه اولى في ظل النظام الرئاسي
الجديد المنتهج في تونس كيف وجدت هذه
الاقاله وهذا التعيين بملابساتها التي
شاهدنا في 24 ساعه الماضيه
هو توازي الصياغ والاجراءات لم نكن نعلم
لماذا عينت بودرن حتى نتفاجا لماذا اقيلت
وما سر على بدن يسري على سيد الحشاني هي
تعيينات منتصف الليل حيث الناس نيام
ويعامل المواطنين فيها معامله الرعايه لا
معامله المواطنين حتى المعلومه لم ترد
كامله فما بالك بالتشارك والتشاور الشعب
التونسي اليوم يعين عليه اشخاص من باب
التجربه ليس لهم سابقا في تناول الوطني
ضيفك الكريم تحدث عن تحديات الاقتصاديه
ولكن المقدمه غير متناسبه مع الاستخلاص في
التحديات الاقتصاديه تتطلب ان يتصدى لها
شخص ذو خلفيه اقتصاديه والحال ان خلفيه
السيده للحشري وهو غير معروف لا داخل ولا
خارجها هي خلفيه قانونيه لم يتحمل اي
مسؤوليه اداره او تسير في حياته ما عليه
مهام داخل
المركزي في الشؤون القانونيه والموارد
البشريه اذا هو حال هل الرئيسي هل الرئيس
ملزم بان يقول لماذا قال السيده بودن
ولماذا وفق اي معايير اختار السيد الحشاني
هل هو ملزم طبعا في ظل النظام الرئاسي
الحالي
في ظل النظام الذي كتب الدستور او السيد
قيس سعيد بنفسه لنفسه ولا يعلم وخفاياه
الا انصاره والراسخون في تفسير نوايا
الرئيس
هو ليس ملزما بشيء هو يتصرف في البلاد وفي
الحكومه تصرف المالك في ملكه ولا يسال عما
يفعل بقي ان كل التحاليل هي تحاليل
اللاحقه وفي تقديمك استاذ عبد القادر ان
تتحدث عن مسارات ثلاث لو تحلينا بالدقه
والموضوعيه لما اقتصر نقاش المسارين
الاولين على ثواني لان الخفايا لا يعلم ان
الرئيس المعايير لا يعلمها الا رئيس
والمواطنون يتبعون على كل شيء كل شيء في
بلاغات من اسطر قليله ورئاسه الجمهوريه
طيب قيصر الصياح ضيفي من تونس ما قاله
الان السيد سمير ديلو تابعته كثيرا ردود
الفعل الشارع التونسي بالقول وكان الرئيس
يتصرف
كباي في تونس وليس رئيس للجمهوريه
التونسيه يفعل ما يشاء ولا يسال عما يفعل
ليس صحيح انا لا اصدق اولا الاستاذ سمير
في في طرحه ولكن ليس صحيح اعتبارا رئيس
يقوم بالتعيينات
التونسي ومن يرى عكس ذلك على ذلك
فليشرحه لنا الرئيس اختار الرئيس الحكومه
باعتبار نظام رئاسي الان
نوفمبرلماني فالرئيس له كامل الصالحيه
الرئيس حكومه اختاره رجل تقني ومدير عام
سابق بالبنك المركزي شو القانونيه
وتشريعيه يعرف كل خفايا القروض المنهوبه
يعرف القروض المعدومه والمفحمه والتي بلغت
مئات الاف المليارات يطلع على كل شيء
والرئيس لم يقم باختبار عشوائي لانما قام
بالتقاط يعني هاتف واعتقد هذا ثم اردت ان
اعرج على ما قال الاستاذ سمير فيما يتعلق
بان الرئيس يختار اشخاصا ليس لهم تاريخ هل
تتذكر
انها قامت بتعيين السيد حماد اجباري وزير
الاول ولم يكن سواء مهندسا بسيطا لا يعرفه
احد وكذلك السيد الحبيب الص
سيد قيصر عندها كان هناك
برلمان وهذا البرلمان يناقش الشارع يعلم
الان الرئيس يقرر وهو من يحدد سياسه هذه
الحكومه ان كانت السيده بودن قد فشلت وعلى
هذا الاساس تم اقالتها من يتحمل مسؤوليه
هذا الفشل وليس ايضا من عين سيد بودن في
ظل الصلاحيات الممنوحه الدستور
نعم سؤالك في محل هو سؤال الهاتف جدا
وممتاز باعتبار ان النظام الرئاسي في كل
انحاء العالم الرئيس هو الذي يختار الرئيس
الحكومه وراينا حتى في الانقباه الملكيه
رئيس يعني الملك اختار رئيس الحكومه رئيس
الحكومه حكومي بالتشكيله ثم يحلب البرلمان
الان نحن في اطار نظام رئاسي وهذا هو
الموجود وهذا النظام الرئاسي ينبع من خلال
الدستور الذي صادق عليه الشعب التونسي
فليكون تلقيحا في يوما ما او استفتاء اخر
ينتقل به الوضع الى نظام شبه رئاسي او
برلماني كما قلنا والذي
واثبت فساله وطيله سبع سنوات ورغم صعوبات
الاقتصاديه فان المواطن التونسي الان لا
يناقشوا مساله احمد الحرشاني اما سيد يوسف
مشاهد الذي كذلك لم يكن له التاريخ لا
سياسي ولا اقتصادي ولا مالي الان نحن في
يجب ان تجاوز كل العالم
لم تجبني عن سؤال من يتحمل مسؤوليه ان
كانت اقاله السيده بودن سببها الفشل ثم ما
الذي يعنيه اقاله رئيس الحكومه وابقاء
الحكومه كما هي من يتحمل المسؤوليه حتى
يعلم الشارع التونسي
المسؤوليه واضح المسؤوليه يتحملها الان
يتحملها رئيس الحكومه اذا كان هناك فشل او
هناك او نقص على مستوى
المناخ الاقتصادي او ضعف على مستوى
النتائج لان السياسه نتائج اقوال وافعال
وليس يعني الراس سواء هنا وهناك في اي
دوله من الدول العالم السياسه هي نتائج
والمواطن لا يعترف الا بنات صعب جدا وضع
اقتصادي وكنا شرحنا لاسباب قديمه وبقطع
النظر عن قديمه وجديده فلنخرج من هذا
النقاش البيزنطي الذي يوجههم على القدماء
ثم نرجع الى جدد الشرفاء ثم نحيل الى
السيد ابو ذنب ثم ما قبل السيد يوسف
الشاهد كل هؤلاء اخفقوا والنتيجه يتحمل
ورئيس الحكومه لانه هو المسؤول الاول عن
السلطه التنفيذيه وردت ان اقول فقط في
لحظات ان السيده نجله بوداني اليوم في
خطاب الرئيس شكلها عامه قامت به مجهودات
لتحقيق نتائج لا يعتبرها كامله وانما تاج
جزئيه وهذا لها بق
حتى بعض المنظمات التي كانت محسوبه او
قريبه على الرئيس قيس سعيد كحركه الشعب
ايضا انتقدت هذه الخطوه ودعت الى رئيس
حكومه ايضا بخلفيه او بجناح سياسي
بالاضافه للجناح الاقتصادي
وبالتالي لماذا كل هذا الجدل تعيين رئيس
حكومه الاتيان رئيس حكومه اخر مساله
طبيعيه وتحدث اذا لماذا كل هذا الجدل سيد
سمير
الانتقال الي انتقادات خجوله ولطيفه
ورقيقه ولكن دعني ان سامحني اتفاعل مع
العجل بالذي كنت اسمع اليها ضيفك الكريم
كان يتحدث عن ان المسؤوليه تتحملها رئيسه
الحكومه وهذا امر غريب وعجيب هذه
الحكومه ليس لاي صلاحيات وليس لها اي سلطه
كل السلطه يتحملها كل الصلاحيات السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه هذا مكتوب في الدستور الذي
كتبه بنفسه لنفسه وهو يشرف على كل
المجالات ولكن في الاخير الذي يتحمل
المسؤوليه هو رئيس الحكومه الذي يغير كما
تغير قطاع الغيار هناك سؤال بسيط لا يحتاج
الى خبير في الاقتصاد او في القانون او في
السياسه اذا كانت السيده بودن ناجحه
فلماذا تم الاستغناء عنها اما اذا كانت
فاشله فمن يجيبنا فيما فشلت وهل تتحمل هي
المسؤوليات ام باقي الاعضاء حكومتها ان
الاشكال اللي هو في الجانب الاقتصادي
والمالي فلماذا يبقى على المسؤولين في هذا
المجال بكل اختصار هذه المنظومه هي منظومه
طيله عامين قد اختبرت فشلت ولم تبقى الا
شعارات والى الالتهابات المطلقه ضيفك
الكريم اعاد مرتين ولم اريد التفاعل معه
في المره الاولى عن الاف المليارات وهو
يتعامل بتساوي مع الارقام تماما
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه عن الاف المليارات
التي تم تبليدها والتي تم انفاقها بلا
حساب من القروض والهبات علما بانه لو كان
يعلم ذلك فعلا في البنك المركزي فلماذا لم
يتكلم الى حد الان ولماذا لم يرد ذلك في
تقارير البنك المركزي الذي التي تقدم
سنويا للسيد رئيس الجمه
وريه السيد
رئيس اللجنه
الاتهامات التي كانت تطلق جزافا قبل ذلك
لم يتكلم احد من السلطه الحاليه الى حد
الان ليتهم وزيرا بعينه او حكومه بعينها
بانه وبكل بساطه القروض والهبات لا تقدم
في اكياس بلاستيكيه او في حقائب وانما
الذين يقدمونها سواء كانت جهات دوليه
ومنظمات او دول فهم يتابعونها ويعلمون
فيما انفقت اكثر مما يعلمها هؤلاء الذين
يتحدثون عنه طيب قيصر لو طلبته منك ان
تجري ولو تقييما اوليا تونس كانت في نظام
طبعا بعد الثوره في نظام برلماني الان قيل
بان النظام هو الذي ادى الى هذا المازق
والانسداد السياسي والاقتصادي في تونس فتم
تغييره الى منهاج ونهاج رئاسي والان اول
تجربه بتغيير رئيس حكومه والاتيان باخر
هل تغير شيء في الاليات التي ادت الى
ازاحه النظام البرلماني والاتيان بالنظام
رئاسي هل هذه المقدمات تشد باننا بان تونس
في الطريق السليم ام ان المشكل ما زال
مطروحا ولم يتغير باعتبار انه تم تغيير
بين النظامين
اما النظام البرلماني اثبت بصراحه اثبت
فشله فشلا ذريعا لان تونس ليس لها تقليص
نظام البرلماني ولا في النظام الشبه
البرلماني وراينا ورات كل شاشات العالم
تقريبا الخصومات السياسيه التي تقريبا على
الجداول الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وكان
المجتمع التونسي
وراينا الارهاب في فتره النظام البرلماني
وكانت القوانين تعطل الى درجه بلغنا 1200
قانون مشروع قانون مطروح بدون نقاش والعنف
الشديد داخل عروقه البرلمان
لم نراه حتى في عهد بن علي الذي كانت فيه
عديده النقائص وكنا ننتقده الان في نظام
رئاسي جديد له سنه ونصف تقريبا رئيس
الحكومه قضت سنتين حتى المعدله الذين راها
في الدول الاوروبيه ودوال الدول شمال شرق
افريقيا والدول الافريقيه جامعات قريب ما
فيها الدول التي حدث فيها انقلابات رؤساء
الحكومه على الاقل فتره زمنيه محدثه تجاوز
المئه يوم يعني يستطيع الشخص ان يقدر فيها
رئيس حكومه رئيس الحكومه الان انضت سنه
ونصف تقريبا في نظام رئاسي تحكمه سلطه
التنفيذيه التي تراس ورئيس حكومه تحت
اشراف رئيس الدوله الذي له كل الصلاحيات
صحيح ما قاله الاستاذ سمير ولكن هذه
صلاحيات لا تعطل مسار الدوله ولا تعطل
القوانين ولا تعدل
ما هي النتائج
وان كانت مقدمات نتائج او نتائج اوليه
لنقول
النتائج الاوليه على الاقل ان تجاوزنا في
مرحله اولى كل صعوبات والمطبات السياسيه
التي كانت تتخبط فيها تونس والمطبات
الامنيه التي كنا نتخبط فيها ويشهد العالم
ان النموذج سنتين لم نتلقى ولو ضربه واحده
ارهابيه عكس ما كنا نتلقاه كل اسبوع
تقريبا بالنزول بالمقرات وبمقرات السياده
وكنا على الانهيار والحرب الاهليه فيه
مطبات هذا النظام الرئاسي فيه هناك فيه
نقائص لا يجادل احد الا المجنون وكل الناس
هذه نقطه مهمه
لماذا الاستعجال والتجربه ما زالت بدايتها
فقط سنه ونصف النظام
الجديد وبالتالي لماذا لا تعطى الفرصه
كامله حتى يتم الحكم بشكل جيد على هذه
التجربه
ولا سمعوا
يتحدث عن بلد اخر غير تونس
فالمعاينه لما يجري في البلاد
عكس ما كان يقولوا تماما السيده جودان
تسلمت البلاد وتعيش ازمه ولكنها تركتها في
وضع كارثي تركت الطوابير
للحصول على قطعه من الخبز تركت ازمات
ومشاكل بعضها فوق بعض سمعه تونس في الحديث
سواء فيما يتعلق
بالمهاجرين او في ما يتعلق
بالاعتقالات وتنفيق القضايا واصطياد
القضاه وعدم احترام قرارات الاداريه
باعاده القضاه المعفيه لظلما الى وظائفهم
كل هذا لا يتحدث عنه المدافعون عن
المنظومه القائمه
ان يطرح بشكل اخر اي المجالات نجحت فيها
هذه السلطه هذه السلطه نجحت في المجال
وحيد هو تكبيس كل السلطات وكل الصلاحيات
في يد شخص واحد علما بان الذي يحول ذلك
الكريم بخصوص توصيل هذا النظام غير دقيقه
للنظام ليس نظام الرئاسيين لا يمكن
مقارنته الا بالاضافه الفرنسي ولا بالنظ
هذا النظام هو نظام رئوي وهو ليس حتى في
مستوى الحكم الفردي وانما هو في مستوى حكم
الفرد اما عن منح فتره للتجربه هذه
الحكومه طالت مدتها تقريبا اكثر من كل
الحكومات التي سرحتها 22 شهرا تقريبا وهي
مده كافيه لتحقق انجازات ولكن بدلا من ذلك
عوينت في جنح الظلام واقيلت في جنح الظلام
ولا يعلم احد لما عينت ولما اقيلت طيب
دقيقه امنحه السيد قيصر الصياح في ظل ما
يردده خاصه الاصوات المعارضه
لسياسات الرئيس قيس سعيد يقولون عندما
يفشل سياسيا يتهم المعارضه وعندما يفشل
اقتصاديا يوجه لومه للحكومه ويقيل رئيستها
ما تعليقك في دقيقه
يعني رئيس لم يوجه لهم هذه المره الى
المعارضه الرئيس له وجه لهم في خطاب واضح
الى منظومه قديمه وهو يتجه الان وهذا اقول
على مسؤوليته من خلال قراءه للخطاب عده
مرات اليوم ان الرئيس تحدث بشكل متكرر عن
منظومه قديمه يواجه كلامه الى رئيس حكومه
جديد يجب هذه المنظومه ان تمحى من على وجه
البسيطه لانها السبب في خراب تونس وخاصه
في الطابع المالي والطابع الاقتصادي ويدرك
جيدا ماذا يقول ويتمسك مره ثانيه بقطع
النظر عن توجهاته وفلسفه الخاصه التي
ننتقدها احيانا يتماسك بان النظام قائم
وليس العيب في النظام ثم انا سيد بودان
الرئيس قال له اليوم بصريح لي شكرا لك عما
انجزتي لكن المرحله القادمه مرحله
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه بامتياز وخاصه في
الطابعه الاجتماعي بطبيعه الحال بطريقه او
باخرى اراد ان يكون قادمه الضيف يا سيد
سمير ديلو عن نظر ته او استشرافه
للمستقبل في ظل ما يحدث الان هو الناج
الحالي سيد سمير
ليس هناك يمكن المحاسبه عليه شخص غير
معلوم الماضي اذا لا يمكن تنبا بالمستقبل
نملك فقط للتوجه الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
والتضرع اليه بالدعاء ان هلكنا فيه الرحمه
وان
الله تعالى ان تكون
التي بدات الربيع العربي
تستحق افضل من هذا تستحق ان يستشار شعبها
وان تستشار نخبه نخبتها تونس تعج
بالكفاءات ولا يمكن ان يعين رئيس حكومتها
من خارج هذه الكفاءات وان يعقد المواطنون
ايديهم وينتظروا ما تجود به الاقدار هل
سينجح رئيس الحكومه ام لا ينجح في كل
الدول المتحرره يتقدم السيد رئيس الحكومه
ببرنامج وعلى اساس هذا البرنامج تتم
محاسبته ولكن للاسف الشديد نحن في جمله لا
هي الجمهوريه المعروفه ولا هو نظام
البيانات الذي انصحت بعض التدوينات
المنسوبه للسيد رئيس الحكومه المعين فيبدو
انه النظام المفضل لديك
من تونس من مدينه رفراف شمال تونس سمير
ديلو المحامي والنجمه التنفيذيه لجبه
الخلاص الوطني المعاهده شكرا جزيلا لك
وكذلك لضيفي من صوت الشرق تونس قيصر
الصياح المحامي والباحث في القانون شكرا
جزيلا لكما الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذن
الله
[موسيقى]